vamos a hacer ahora algunos problemas
más interesantes algo padre la
probabilidad es que siempre podemos
hacer problemas más interesantes así que
bien vamos a pensar de nuevo en una
moneda justa y voy a suponer que la voy
a lanzar al aire tres veces voy a
echarme tres volados y me voy a
preguntar por la probabilidad de que al
menos me salga un águila entonces quiero
la probabilidad de que al menos al menos
al menos haya un águila un águila en
tres volados en tres
volados
así que bien cuál sería esta
probabilidad pues un modo de hacerlo es
enlistar todos los eventos posibles que
ya lo hice en el vídeo pasado todos
eventos posibles en el primer volado dos
eventos posibles en el segundo volado y
dos eventos posibles en el tercer volado
dos por dos por dos me daba ocho así que
aquí están los ocho eventos y lo único
que tengo que hacer ahora es contar
cuáles de esos en cuáles de estos
eventos aparece al menos un águila en el
primero parece en el segundo tercero
cuarto quinto sexto séptimo entonces en
todos salvo en esta última me aparece un
águila así que siete de esos ocho
eventos igualmente probables me daban
una situación deseada me apareció un
águila pero quizás ustedes estén
preguntando bueno y no hay otro modo de
hacer esto qué pasaría si dijera por
ejemplo al menos un águila en 20 volados
entonces tendría que hacer una tabla
gigantesca si quisiera contar todas las
opciones así que no habrá un modo de
hacer este problema que más o menos
utiliza estas ideas
y la respuesta es que sí de hecho lo que
vamos a hacer es cambiar este problema
vamos a pensarlo de otro modo que va a
ser muchísimo más fácil y eso es algo
que es muy común en los exámenes cuando
tengan un problema que se vea como un
poco difícil de pensar en el por ejemplo
aquí si quisiera calcular directamente
esto este pues quizás calcularía la
probabilidad de obtener un águila en el
primero pero luego en el segundo
necesito tomar en cuenta lo que pasa en
el primero entonces sería muy complicado
a veces pensar en el problema de un modo
más sencillo es lo que se requiere hacer
así que mejor vamos a pensar
alternativamente en vamos a
concentrarnos en la probabilidad de no
obtener
no obtener puros soles
en 3
volados
y lo que vamos a ver es que estas dos
cosas son en realidad equivalentes
porque qué pasa si no obtuve puros o les
tuve que haber obtenido un águila
entonces al menos obtuve un águila en
tres volados por eso estas dos cosas son
equivalentes ahora cuánto banesto pues
esto es lo mismo que 1 - la probabilidad
de obtener puros soles en 3 volados ok
entonces la probabilidad de obtener
puros soles sería la probabilidad de
obtener un sable en el primero un sol en
el segundo y un sol en el tercero y por
qué pasa esto vamos a pensar un segundo
en por qué pasa esto pues la razón de
fondo es que si yo considero la
probabilidad de no obtener puros soles
no obtener
puros soles
y la suma con la probabilidad de
obtener puros soles
pues entonces cuánto me debe de dar esto
estos dos eventos son mutuamente
excluyentes obtengo puros soles o por
ahí apareció un águila entonces no
obtuve puros soles y sólo sucede alguna
de las dos alternativas así que estos
dos eventos son mutuamente excluyentes y
además son exhaustivos cualquier grupo
de volados o está en esta categoría o
está en esta categoría así que juntos
son todos los eventos posibles así que
la suma de las probabilidades debe ser 1
porque estas dos cosas son todos los
casos que no podrían pasar de modo que
la probabilidad de no obtener puros
soles es igual a uno menos la
probabilidad de obtener puros soles que
es esta de aquí ahora bien qué pasa cómo
puedo calcular esta probabilidad pues ya
lo hemos hecho antes y esto es un
ejercicio sencillo tengo una entre dos
posibilidades de obtener un solo en el
primer volado tengo una entre dos de
obtener un sol en el segundo volado y
uno entre dos de obtener un sol en el
tercer volado como
y los volados son independientes esta
probabilidad simplemente es este
producto así que todo esto sería igual a
1 menos un medio por un medio por un
medio lo que sería igual a 1 menos un
medio por un medio es un cuarto por un
medio es un octavo así que uno menos un
octavo que es siete octavos que es justo
lo que habíamos obtenido antes bien
vamos a aplicar esto a un problema un
poco más complicado y divertido bien
vamos a pensar ahora que de nuevo tengo
mi moneda justa y de nuevo voy a echar
menos volados ahora me voy a echar 10
volados y de nuevo me voy a preguntar
por la probabilidad de obtener al menos
al menos
un sol
en 10 volados
ahora la misma idea que usamos antes la
probabilidad de obtener al menos un sol
en 10 volados es igual a la probabilidad
de no
obtener
obtener puras águilas
águilas
en 10 volados
esto está muy largo para escribir y de
nuevo esto es lo mismo que 1 - la
probabilidad de obtener
obtener
puras
águilas
en 10 volados en 10 volador
y de nuevo esto es algo relativamente
sencillo de calcular
nosotros sabemos calcular estas
probabilidades bastante fácil entonces
sería uno menos la probabilidad de
obtener puras águilas en 10 volados es
decir águila tras águila tras águila
tras águila y eso cuánto es la
probabilidad de obtener un águila en
cada volado es de un medio así que sería
un medio para obtener un águila en el
primer volado como los volados son
eventos independientes también tendría
un medio en el segundo volado por un
medio en el tercer volado por un medio
en el cuarto volado y así hasta llegar a
10 van 56
10 ok y cuánto es esto pues veamos sería
uno menos
un medio por un medio bueno en el
numerador va a ser 1 no sólo es uno por
uno por uno y el denominador va a ser
dos por dos por dos por 22 a la 10 2 por
12 4 por 2 8 por 2 16 32 64 128 156 512
así que uno menos uno entre mil 24 y
esto es lo mismo que pues uno es lo
mismo que 1024 entre 1024
ya eso le voy a restar menos 1 entre el
y esa humedad 1.023 entre 1024
y sólo por diversión saqué mi
calculadora para escribir esto como un
porcentaje así que 1000 23 entre 1024
cuánto nos va
esto en porcentaje sería el 99.9 por
ciento así que esto es el
99.9 por ciento de los casos así que en
realidad la probabilidad de al menos
sacar un sol en días volados es altísima
casi con toda seguridad sacan un sol en
diez volados y noten que en este
problema si lo hubiéramos tratado de
resolver
enumerando todos los casos posibles como
acá entonces realmente hubiera sido un
desastre porque tuvimos 1024 casos
distintos y no se hubiera llevado todo
el tiempo suelo escribir la tabla así
que bien estos dos modos de pensar en un
problema y esta idea de cambiar el modo
de ver las cosas para simplificar son
bastante bastante útiles